ANTHONY BUSHONG: Hi,
I'm Anthony Bushong,
developer advocate at Google.
And welcome to GKE Essentials.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Did you know that GKE clusters
can scale up to 15,000 nodes?
Owning a cluster with that
sheer scale is hard for me
to comprehend at times.
But let's dive into it together.
This video is the first part
of a two-part introduction
to building large-scale
GKE clusters.
Over the course of
these videos, we'll
talk at a high level
around two key areas--
one, why you might
consider building clusters
with thousands of
nodes, and two,
what considerations
you should account
for when designing clusters
to be able to scale.
Kubernetes especially
shines for those
of you looking to build a
platform to run your company's
workloads.
It gives you a means
for abstracting away
infrastructure.
No need to directly
deploy workloads
to a specific machine.
Rather, you deploy
it to the cluster,
and Kubernetes will make
sure it runs somewhere.
It also gives you
declarative APIs
that codify a workload's
characteristics
and enforces that behavior.
You can even extend these
APIs with your own definitions
of how workloads should run.
This is why one of the
founders of Kubernetes
went as far as calling
the open-source technology
a platform for
building platforms.
Now, these platforms
that you build
could be home to a set of large,
resource-intensive workloads,
such as batch processing
or machine learning.
Or they could also be the
generalized way in which you
enable developers to
access infrastructure
for their various and
potentially differing
workloads.
It should be noted
that when you're
building multi-tenant
clusters, the harder
isolation or stronger
boundaries that you require
between these workloads,
the more likely
it is you should consider using
multiple smaller clusters.
Nevertheless, using fewer
large-scale clusters
in some of these cases can
help in a handful of ways.
One, they can help you
minimize the number of clusters
you have to actively manage.
This helps with problems
like configuration drift
across clusters or juggling
multiple concurrent upgrade
cycles.
Two, you can more easily
handle resource spikes.
If you're building
a platform, you
may have many different
teams as users,
each with their own
plans for rolling out
their own workloads
to the platform
or scaling up their workloads.
Building a cluster that
can scale to larger sizes
can help absorb these
varying demands concurrently.
And finally, for those of you
building specialized platforms
for batch processing
or machine learning,
building a large-scale
cluster brings the simplicity
of the Kubernetes
API to these complex,
performance-intensive workloads.
Even if you're not looking
to build a cluster that's
15,000 nodes, you can still
realize these benefits
by building a cluster
that can scale to house
large amounts of resources.
So let's talk about
considerations
for designing and building a
large-scale cluster like this.
When it comes down to it,
as a platform builder,
you are providing a
contract to your end
users and their workloads.
You ask them to
package their workload
in a container with assurances
that your platform will
run that workload reliably.
So at the heart of building
large-scale clusters
is not just the concept of
adding more nodes or more pods,
but rather, figuring out
how to maintain your cluster
reliability when doing so.
Of course, we can't cover every
single design consideration
for large-scale clusters
in this episode.
But let's dive into where
you should start thinking.
It's important to
think of cluster design
across two categories.
There are the considerations
at the greater Kubernetes
level, which revolves
around the Kubernetes API
and their objects, such as
pods, services, namespaces.
And these are not
specific or limited
to any one
infrastructure provider.
Then there are considerations
at the GKE level, which
include Google Cloud
resources, such as VPCs,
underlying compute, storage,
and GKE specific features
that help tune your cluster
to reach these larger sizes.
We'll actually cover the
Google Cloud and GKE parts
in part two of this series,
so let's cover the Kubernetes
resources first.
Kubernetes
scalability is defined
by the special-interest
group focused on scalability
as a multidimensional envelope.
Within this envelope,
your cluster
will work and do so reliably.
This envelope has
configuration limitations
at various dimensions.
It could be the number of
pods, the number of namespaces,
the number of secrets.
So when designing a
cluster for large scale,
it helps to understand
and start thinking
about how your cluster will
fit within this envelope.
Now, I definitely don't work
with multidimensional envelopes
on a day-to-day basis,
so let's actually
talk a little bit about how
an envelope like this works.
In the envelope of
Kubernetes scalability,
dimensions are not always
independent of one another.
An example.
In Kubernetes, we
have the ability
to run 110 pods per node.
We're also able to run thousands
of nodes in a given cluster.
But to do both at the same time?
This likely would
result in an unreliable
cluster, as you are stretching
multiple dimensions too far--
pods per node, nodes, and
total pods in the cluster.
In a scenario like this, knowing
how these dimensions relate
to one another can help
you make adjustments,
like changing the maximum
number of pods per node
in your cluster.
In GKE, for these
large-scale clusters,
we generally recommend
considering fewer pods per node
than the maximum.
A good starting benchmark we've
seen with successful users
is roughly 30 pods per node.
The next thing to
consider is, scaling
to the maximum in
any one direction
can taper your ability to scale
across the other dimension.
So it's important to think about
what resources your platform
could push to the limit.
A highly specialized
cluster to serve
as a batch-processing
platform, for example,
might have numerous pods
being created and deleted
at the same time, depending
on the status of jobs
that are running.
And this will affect pod churn.
A multi-tenant
enterprise platform
might have hundreds of workloads
across hundreds of teams,
each isolated to their
own set of namespaces.
It's important to
plan around what
is most critical to make
your platform on Kubernetes
work for your users and to test
those dimensions one at a time
and independently.
Finally, all the resources your
platform uses in Kubernetes
share an upper bound, which
is set by the underlying state
system for Kubernetes, etcd.
This not only includes
the Kubernetes objects
you're probably familiar
with-- deployments, secrets,
stateful sets, et cetera--
but also the resources that are
created using custom resource
definitions.
In fact, many
open-source technologies
built atop Kubernetes
utilize this
to persist their own objects
through the Kubernetes control
plane that their own set of
controllers interact with.
All of these objects are
subject to etcd's underlying
limitations, such as 800
mebibytes per object type
and the overall total
storage of etcd.
Given this, we
recommend understanding
the implications of
what is actually getting
created in your cluster.
For example, the built-in
Kubernetes job resource
requires certain configurations
to ensure that resources
are cleaned up upon completion.
Custom resources can
also expand one resource
into several others, such
as pipeline runs Tekton.
These are not bad things.
If you need to run Kubernetes
jobs or custom resources,
like what Tekton
provides, great.
But it's important to know
their behavior when building
a platform for your end users.
Now that we've taken a
high-level walkthrough
of Kubernetes
scalability, we'll need
to cover how to design around
GKE features and Google Cloud
infrastructure to support these
large-scale clusters, which
we'll cover in part two.
In the meantime, take a
look at these resources
to better understand
the Kubernetes
scalability dimensions
that we discussed today.
Thank you for your time,
and we will see you
on the next episode, part
two in GKE Essentials.